even as people reject british history
they're being incredibly british and
isn't it the ultimately
the most british thing is to be
self-deprecating and say oh we're
terrible the only the only problem with
that is you end up an orphan
if you say my family is rotten you
wouldn't believe what my family did
about like 200 years ago what nothing to
do with my family well it's all very
well but you wind up an orphan and
ultimately as i've found when you buy a
dog you need someone to walk the dog for
you and if you've written off the rest
of the family uh you've got no one to do
it so no wonder we're feeling so lonely
when we've when we isolate ourselves not
only from people alive now but people
from the past
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is a historian
leader writer for the telegraph and the
author of whatever happened to tradition
tim stanley welcome to trigonometry
hello
it's great to have you on that was a
very short hello from you
welcome on the show thrilled this is the
podcast is it
when my first when my last book came out
about seven years ago if you didn't get
on the bbc or channel four your book
basically didn't happen and it's so
fascinating that there are now all these
different podcasts that you can go on
and your book can reach different people
and new audiences and this is one of my
favorites
well before we get into talking about
your book which we both really really
enjoyed tell everybody a little bit
about who you are how are you where you
are what has been your journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
rather than on the bbc
i'm a cancerian
[Laughter]
is a good place to start that tells you
everything you need to know about me um
i was born in kent
i
had father and a mother no brothers and
sisters it's quite a small family
i went to grammar school i then went to
cambridge where i studied history i fell
in love with america
and ended up trying to spend as much
time over there as possible
i
studied wrote about taught a bit of
american history sussex university royal
holloway
but i got sick of the fact that i could
literally name all the people who'd read
my books
because that's the fate of an academic
book hardly anyone reads them
so i decided to get into journalism and
over about a year or two i just
constantly badgered different newspapers
i worked my way up from the bottom i
really did i had no contacts and
eventually i convinced the daily
telegraph to use me as a sort of a
a sort of an assistant
comment type person in america and
somehow i managed to bagel my way into
the newspaper and i ended up working as
a leader writer so from history to
journalism that's basically the
trajectory of my career and you talk
about popularizing uh your work getting
it out in front of more than just a
handful of academics i think your
current latest book about tradition is
so
poignant at this moment in time and i
we've been thinking about this on the
show quite a bit and we've spoken to
different people about it and it kind of
struck me a few weeks ago we were
interviewing posey parker who used to be
a gender-critical feminist right and one
of the sort of key moments of that
interview was her saying bring back
shame
right when talking about stuff before
that i remember we've interviewed a
christian catholic
christian catholic a catholic in america
called mary eberstad who wrote a book
about how uh the sexual revolution
created identity politics yes uh we
interviewed a lady called alex kosciutta
who talked about how
she said i don't have an ideology i just
know that the closer my lifestyle is to
my grandmother's you know pickling
cucumbers for winter and all of that uh
living in a small town in romania the
better i feel as a woman and we found
that actually those interviews have been
most popular with young women
your colleague madeline grant the
telegraph wrote a piece about how
she is one of a number of millennials
who don't believe in god who now go to
church yeah and i think all of this at
least in my opinion is part of a a
feeling among particularly young people
but i think all of us really that we've
been sold some kind of lie uh and i
think if i was to summarize that lie i
would say that it's the idea that
you know the faster we throw in the bin
50 000 years of cultural development the
better freer
more exciting and thrilling and
wonderful our lives are going to be and
i think a lot of people are starting to
find that that isn't the case for them
is do do you have something to say on
that because i feel like you ought to
well i i i feel like that's the book uh
so
uh yes i agree with you you use the word
freedom that's absolutely critical uh we
are nowadays taught that that is the
highest value
and we are encouraged to think that we
can be the authors of our own story
that by the way is a tradition it's a
western tradition it's a very western
way of thinking so ironically by
pursuing freedom and tearing up
tradition we're actually being very
traditionally western
on the other hand it's it's first of all
a myth it's nonsense you don't write
yourself no one can even when you kick
against where you came from you're
recognizing where you came from and
decisions we made on your behalf about
the way you are brought up that are
almost invisible so again that point
about it being a western tradition
one's pursuit of oneself
is the product of a certain upbringing
it's the way you're raised is to to
aspire to certain things so first of all
you you can't escape the past
but secondly the idea that those
thousands of years there isn't something
in there that's not valuable that we
that precisely because it's been
thrashed out over that that period of
time uh they haven't whittled down
certain basic problems and found certain
solutions and coping mechanisms the idea
that you'd want to junk that social
knowledge i think is absolutely mad let
alone the idea that you could come up
with something better just off the top
of your head
so i i think what you're describing that
people looking backwards is part of that
part of that process
what i would want to stress however is i
mean you started with the word shame
and sometimes when we talk about
tradition
uh it is it is talked about in terms of
um punishments negativity some things
we've all become a bit too decadent and
we need to be self-disciplined there's a
very positive dimension to tradition as
well i mean the other the other thing
you described there was people trying to
be
more like their grandparents well that's
more of a positive thing making your own
stuff walking rather than taking the car
uh not using plastic bag well there's
some getting life that's simpler and
more traditional in its style
and that's really much more what the
book's about this is this is not a
handbag over the head of western man i'm
not saying you you dirty little thing
you must go back to the 1950s on the
contrary uh the further you get you look
back you might actually find some points
of liberation and color which are really
rather exciting and
upbeat
and it's a really really interesting
point because it just feels that
we tend to be progressing not only fast
but at warp speed now is that
me
yeah and and and
yeah yes you're getting no no no no no
no no this is this is a very important
point um that i sort of concluded in the
course of writing this that i've noticed
that many people in my generation
are nostalgic not just for their own
youths
but use that came before them
that things have moved so fast even in
their own lifetime
that actually their points of reference
for how they would like to live are not
when they were a kid but their father or
their grandparents
so uh if you turn on the telly
i i'm struck by how it's all uh call a
midwife downton abbey it's 1950s or
1920s or 1930s there are very few rosy
shows about the 1990s no one can be
bothered to go back to that particular
period so my youth isn't really
represented there at all if you think
about when we went through the pandemic
what were the uh what were the
historical parallels we reached for it
was the war bit bizarre because there
have been actual pandemics you could
reach for as much better allegories for
analogies for how to behave but that
looms so large as a moral story that for
many of us we reach back to that and i
agree i think it comes down to the pace
of change has been so great within a
lifetime uh that actually for
the past offers a sense of the solid
because it's unchanging so people reach
back to something that came even before
because it seems a little more solid
and it's not just even been in the last
few years but even when you if you take
during the pandemic it seemed that the
world speeded up even more
the moment george floyd was murdered it
just seemed to be that we just shifted
everything just shifted again yes in a
way that was very very confusing for a
lot of people when people were almost
had to question themselves and think to
themselves am i now racist i don't think
i'm racist but am i now racist yes yes
and
it's it's not just that circumstances
change but also it feels like morality
changes
and language changes which is very
unusual for that to happen again within
not just a lifetime but a space of a
couple of years
so to take the lockdown for example um i
thought that recognized british value
pre-lockdown was mind your own business
that's what i that's what i thought we
were all about in this country and i
like the night that's why i came here
but then i then i discovered almost
overnight that it wasn't just that that
uh that that value was contestable or
problematic um but actually that the
opposite was true and it was a british
value to keep an eye out on people
yeah
so it and i like that these things are
not written in stone i i appreciate that
values change dramatically over time i
just think it's a little unusual for
them to change so far so dramatically
and as i say for the language to shift
with it so that one is no longer an
expectant mother in the course of your
lifetime you can suddenly wake up and
discover that you're in fact a pregnant
person
and that these changes in language
affect meaning and they affect how
people feel and assess themselves so it
actually feels increasingly as though
old definitions of what it meant to be
human
are built on shifting sands so no no
wonder people are looking back
looking back to points in the past which
as i say because it's happened and it's
not it's therefore it's unchangeable
it's immutable people look back and
think well i prefer that when i
understood what a woman or what a lady
was to this this period of extraordinary
rapid change so are you saying that
we're sort of like
we've we feel like we're holding on to a
train from which we're about to full
full out and we just craved the time
when it wasn't going quite so fast where
we felt a little bit more secure yes and
that's a myth
there has always been change right um
and uh one of the things that really
struck me when researching this book
because i didn't really know a lot about
the 19th century so ended up having to
do an insane amount of crammed reading
about the 19th century i was struck by
how many complaints made uh in the 19th
century could be made now
and they were related to
industrialization the rise of the train
newspapers all these sorts of things the
19th century people were there was a
brilliant psychiatrist a liberal zionist
called max simon nordau who wrote a
brilliant book called degeneration i
think
in which he describes the condition of
his patience
and he concludes that the world has gone
mad on the basis of the people who he's
treating and he actually more or less
predicts what would become the second
world war in about 30 or 40 years time
he's remarkably prophetic
and it is the overloading information
it's the pace of change and that's
already there in the 19th century but to
answer the question about uh holding on
to something yes that that is what the
feeling is
um and i think that's partly where
brexit and trump come in i think that's
part of what we've been through in the
last four or five years
the the language of uh take back control
i think it's it's not just it was it was
misinterpreted as simply about restoring
parliament or or controlling borders i
think it's even bigger than that i think
it's actually the individual wishes to
be able to actually say to his story to
say to history stop there i want to take
stock i want to understand my
relationship with you and i want to re
regain a sense of uh investment and a
stake in my own life and is it the
internet that's done this or is there
more to it than that tim i think the
internet has accelerated it as i say
it's really a two or three hundred year
process but definitely it's become much
faster with the communications
revolution there's no denying that
um but i also think it is the natural
terminus of of the western tradition as
as i mentioned at the beginning uh we we
have it hard-wired into our dna to
question things constantly and analyze
things and scrutinize them um and the
internet has helped to accelerate that
process but it's also the atomization of
society isn't it the this
this progress that we seem to be on and
we seem to devalue community
and promote identity and that to me just
seems
a way to to the mad house isn't it yes
and no because i i'm sympathetic towards
identity politics to the extent that i
think it is a symptom as much as a cause
of everything we've described
it's understandable that the atomized
individual looking for an identity
might reach out for a group
and say okay that makes sense of my life
and if you look at black lives matter
for instance like when black lives
matter says we need to deconstruct the
nuclear family you might just read that
and say well they just hate families
that's not quite true they actually talk
about going back to older forms of
family they see the nuclear family as a
white imposition a modern invention etc
but they're not anti-family or community
by any means it's just one sense is that
they feel no investment in the current
social structures so they are
individuals looking for something else
so i so i see that as a symptom but
undeniably yes it does also ironically
help to perpetuate this problem of us
becoming more and more like individuals
and of course that's not just a
and sometimes when people talk about
atomization it's a little bit
theoretical but we all know in our
everyday lives that it's it's a it is a
lived reality
um because because uh for instance i i
have as i sort of mentioned the
beginning i have a very small family i
live alone i i'm a classic example of an
atomized individual in the 21st century
uh we don't live the way that we used to
which is not just as part of large
families but also crucially large
kinship networks where you have where if
something goes wrong you don't just have
to fall back on your wife or your mum
and dad you might have extended
relationships of aunts and uncles etc
etc so the actual
pattern of our lives has changed
it's a very very good point
when i was reading your book
i kept thinking about religion
because when i was younger and you know
reading dawkins a god delusion you just
think to yourself where do we need
religion we have science now yes we have
logics we have facts yeah and then we've
taken religion out and you're looking
around going maybe we did need it yeah
yeah well those facts won't uh comfort
you when someone dies
they just don't
this is this is the problem with them
i mean you mentioned uh someone going to
my friend maddie grant going to church
without believing in god um see that's
very interesting it raises the question
why if you don't believe in god it could
seem a bit mad because the whole point
of of the church is to worship god and
if you don't
but but is that true though tim because
the the the shift from the pagan
religions or the or the sort of multi um
whatever they're called uh
polytheistic religions right the romans
the greeks et cetera ordinary people
weren't allowed in the temple right and
the shift from that to christianity
included making the church the house of
god i don't think madeleine i don't know
i haven't spoken to her about this
specific issue but i think young people
who go to church without necessarily
believing in god do so for the community
element of it rather than
rather than the belief in god and maybe
just a sort of meditative practice as
well a place where you no longer for one
time in your life are obsessed with
yourself yes yeah and there is something
beyond you which i think a lot of people
pray for now i i'd agree with that
except that and maddie's a very good
friend they don't want to talk about her
without her talking about another person
that he's not here
but ultimately if you wanted to do that
you could for instance join a political
party i i don't think it's just the
community yeah uh and i would say first
of all what is it that draws the
community it is the belief so everyone
else around you probably believes in god
even if you don't they are there for a
reason and second of all uh once you are
there what is what is it you're hit with
well it's not just the community is it
it's either the preaching
or it's the experience of transcendence
depending upon the kind of church that
you go to
what i would say is to because i i am
religious but i i i made a point when
writing the book not to make it all
about religion i said religion until the
very end um partly because i've learned
from doing things like thought for the
day that this moment you try to inject
religion into the conversation you lose
someone so it's better to
introduce it very subtly
but also because i i wanted to make the
point that traditions serve human needs
some are indeed just invented and
imposed and that can be horrible and
fundamentalism is an example of that but
in most cases they've actually evolved
over time to meet people's very basic
needs
and even if you don't feel in your heart
belief in god i think you can see the
psychological benefit and what it's
speaking to and there are certain
moments in people's lives typically when
they give birth when they get married
when they die or when a
loved one dies when they instinctively
reach for the church
and it's partly because the church has
developed a language
that we do not have
at those moments these experiences are
so profound
that there's almost no everyday language
to describe them how do you feel when
your husband or wife has died the church
lends you the language
and even if you don't believe in
reincarnation or going to heaven or
whatever it almost doesn't matter you're
allowing someone with thousands of years
of experience to
speak on your heart and provide comfort
and that and so so you don't know you
don't have to believe but i think that
the belief can come because you realize
that what's what's generating this
tradition what sustains it is the belief
and over time i think that can come it's
a community as well it's the way it
binds you together i was raised catholic
we always used to go to sunday mass five
o'clock and used to sit down used to see
the same faces now even if you didn't
know them
in any great depth there's a comfort to
seeing the same people again it anchors
you in community yeah and also it gives
you something to do on a sunday morning
don't again don't knock that the lack of
structure in the week um i have a
slightly odd week because i work at
weekends and sometimes it's just not
possible to do my usual mass on a sunday
and on those days i just feel lost i
i've lost that sense of structure to the
week um really that's what religion is
about it it marks the year it gives
structure to your year the liturgical
year is wonderful it explains to you
what you're going through things don't
just happen to you
you actually have a sort of dialogue
with the universe you you have a sense
of place within it
so tim now that we've lost all the
people who are uncomfortable
well france is now both non-believers
but um it's it's a very interesting
conversation and i keep coming back in
my mind to the point you made at the
very beginning which is
it is a core tenant of western
civilization
to question and to seek freedom yes
is that an inevitably self-destructive
force then because i i suspect one of
the reasons that we believe in god less
than we used to whether people like
francis and i exist even is that we want
to be free of the external impositions
on us of the authority saying don't do
this and if you do that then you're bad
and wrong and you'll be punished and and
you will be looked badly upon by your
community are we careering off the deep
end here with this endless pursuit of
freedom are we or or is there going to
be some kind of natural built-in
mechanism that says to us okay we've got
the freedom now let's just make sure
that we don't lose it by doing something
else yeah i i think an important caveat
to my argument is that
even
within those sort of traditions that i'm
saying look back to you'll still find
that that sort of dna strand of the
search for freedom and moral autonomy so
you find it within christianity as well
which is why it is at once a very
conservative religion a religion of
churches it's also a religion of
reformations and of constant change and
every generation or so the church will
settle and like it's it's it's sort of
it's found its place in the world and
someone will come along and say no it's
not pure enough
um
and there's also this feeling within
christianity that faith must be chosen
so so there are lots of ways in which
even those things that i would like us
to look back to and revive i recognize
that that desire for freedom is within
them but yes i do think it is
self-destructive and i think it's a real
problem um and
what i what i'm arguing in the book is
that uh i'd like people to look a little
bit beyond i'd like people to look
before the enlightenment because there
was a medieval consensus which was very
different which saw freedom in a very
different way i'd like them to look
beyond europe a little bit because uh
there is russia there is japan there are
other countries which deal with the same
problems we have and handle them in a
very different way and to just think
beyond themselves and beyond the desire
for liberation constantly and to look
for freedom in things which are settled
and that that's a key point of the book
that
you really can't have liberty without
order
um and there are certain forms of there
are certain traditions like notions of
authority uh which we just we just
recoil against nowadays but the point is
that these things defend liberty uh
because you you
if there's chaos ultimately you can't be
free and i and i i do fear that's where
we're headed towards i flinched a little
bit when you said the word order i think
we've all sort of we all now so not all
a lot of us think about it as a sort of
ordnance like that's right that's the
vibe of that word yes um and it's
difficult but if i could step in there
if you take the lockdown for instance i
would say that a traditional society i
would hope
wouldn't have needed those draconian
rules
because the public would have been so
public spirited that they would have
done the right thing without being told
what to do
when you have a breakdown in moral order
it requires the state to step in to tell
people what to do
so the less there is this sort of
organic instinctive understanding of a
moral consensus the more you actually
fall back upon the state to instruct
people to behave a certain way that
makes sense
let me pick up on something you said
earlier because we're both fascinated by
history and you were talking about how
in the medieval times there was a
consensus that was very different around
the issue of freedom talk to us about
the historical evolution of this very
idea of individual autonomy and freedom
how has that changed over time well it's
always there because of course the roots
of the enlightenment really come from
humanism and the renaissance and that
itself was looking back to greek
philosophy so it's always there but i i
think a a key element of the medieval um
of the medieval attitude towards uh the
individual and towards life was this
idea of everything being interconnected
that you you are defined by your
relationship
not just by yourself and how you feel
but your relationship to other people
um so whereas now we begin from the
point of view of who am i how do i feel
and we're intensely psychological uh
instead an older more traditional
approach towards life is to define
oneself in relationship to other people
you find this in in more traditional
societies as well
so you might say not just uh i am a
woman but i am a mother uh i am a wife
um or indeed you may say i'm a nurse as
well so i think that's that's why that's
one way in which it's slightly different
um but if you live in a god-ordered
universe you start from a different set
of first principles to the ones we have
now which again are are very much about
negotiation with morality whereas if you
just say look things are as they are
because this is the this is the
understanding as we this is the world as
we understand it as we have been told it
and as god has ordered it that doesn't
mean there is no freedom it just means
that um
it just means that you're
the way the way you act starts from
different a different set of first
principles
isn't the problem with our society is
that we don't worship god we just
worship ourselves now
and you see that with social media with
instagram you know it's entire focus on
the self so isn't part of the problem
with talking about traditionalism is
that we live in a society that
incentivizes us to be selfish and
narcissistic because we see the people
who are selfish and narcissistic they're
the ones who get to the top they're the
celebrities they're the bankers they're
the wealthy etc etc yeah yeah and and
actually in the medieval period people
are making precisely that complaint so
that's the age group you belong
i mean those characters you could read
the canterbury tales and you'd see those
representations there so that that is a
that that is a human ongoing thing i
mean it's it's some of the scriptures
are about complaining about those uh
attitudes as well so i'd say it's
eternal but i i do agree uh i think
we've become over psychological and
everything is over internalized um is it
see i'm reluctant to just to say it's
because we don't believe in god partly
because again i will lose lots of people
who i'd like to see by the book
i i think i think
you can say god is a useful
it is useful
in the sense that it draws our attention
away from the self and to something else
another way of thinking about it is what
are your points of reference for
aspiration
this is one thing that really troubles
me i think we're one of the first
societies in history that has very
little moral aspiration
that doesn't that doesn't have a strong
sense of this is the kind of person you
should be it's constantly being
negotiated and it's constantly up for
debate um but there there is no there is
no there is less and less of a sense of
ideal and that's part of what religion
does is it provides you with ideal human
beings and ideal types crucially with
moral content so they're not just ideal
because they are beautiful or strong or
anything like that but because they are
good people
so
in christianity saints are very often
poor
uh they're mad
they're very difficult people but
they're extraordinary people who put
their own life on the line for other
people that that should be who your
ideal is
in this society insofar as we have
ideals um it's it's either for the rich
people who made it and that's who you
want to aspire to or it's for a set of
things which i would describe as not
being really moral i mean this is frank
ferrari's point is that we we obsess
about
we've got hooked on words that have no
moral content so uh so one of the ideals
of our society is to be diverse
that's just a descriptor
just to say that this room this room is
diverse doesn't mean any of us are moral
people in it we're hey we've got 10 out
of 10 because we're a diverse group of
people so what that doesn't say anything
about us and our moral character another
is inclusion
well hey you could include a murderer in
your party if you wanted to again no
moral content so
religion doesn't it religion offers
ideals but crucially
they are usually ideals with a moral
content
tim so as a sort of you're talking about
moral history in a way here and you
bring up those the evolution of language
that's something i've studied very
carefully myself as a former translator
comedian i obsess about words all the
time and i've there's a chapter in my
book about the evolution of language
but you mentioned diversity you
mentioned inclusion why have these
particular
i mean non-ideals ideals right
things that as you say don't have that
moral content but nonetheless we hold up
as being ideal particularly here in
britain
why are we so
keen to focus on that
at the moment
um i think partly because it's easy i
mean the irony is it's sold to us as a
struggle to get those things but
actually they're quite easy to achieve
um and it's partly because we live in a
capitalist order
and it's something that capitalism can
do without having to make an enormous
sacrifice it's something businesses can
do uh businesses can go diverse and they
can sell like diversity and they can
sell themselves as diverse and they can
gain a huge customer base like hsbc
uh by pushing uh certain woke things and
selling themselves to us with that
they're not actually giving their money
away are they no i mean
well they're laundering drug dealers
money at the same time you've got a
portrait of stalin on the wall and this
is by no means to endorse marxism but
at least that aimed for a genuine
redistribution of wealth and power one
of the frustrating things about this new
moral paradigm is it doesn't actually do
that
it doesn't actually
level anything or make anyone more equal
or
make society
genuinely fairer
so i i think that's one reason is
because it's it's an easy form of of
moral progress it's easy to track
and it doesn't cost very much money hold
on jimmy say it doesn't make make it
fairer what about minorities that have
been historically discriminated against
and now their lives are a lot easier and
they're being that's true that that's
unfair and i i that that's unfair me to
say that yeah you're quite right and
that that's that's a fair point but
i i suppose being old-fashioned and
having in my youth being a socialist
myself i just always thought that i i
measure fairness in
in the genuine redistribution of wealth
and power and i don't actually see that
happening
and there must be a reason why bae
systems is pro diversity
the company for those of you don't know
makes uh british armaments yeah and they
spot they sponsored a pride festival i
think uh in the isle of wight somewhere
i just thought that's extraordinary an
equal opportunity weapons dealer yeah
that is morality turned upside down and
it's not a morality that would be
recognized a hundred years ago when the
left pacifistic and genuinely into
redistribution and into getting rid of
all arms would have thought associations
with that kind of group to be absolutely
abhorrent but
that's so interesting because a lot of
these companies are like that manchester
city
again supporting blm
their manager came out and spoke about
the evils of slavery
you go
but you're owned by qataris
[Laughter]
right you know
you just got yeah
it's so paper thin yes i i would
understand if they hid it but they don't
even bother hiding it no they just put a
pride flag or blm and then they go well
that's it yeah that's all we need to do
and it won't be happening in the country
that's the sponsor i'm sure yeah yeah
yeah i'm looking forward to harry kane
wearing a uh a pride he had the rainbow
uh captain's zombat i'm sure he's not
going to be wearing that in qatar
and look a lot of people believe it and
a lot of people genuinely want to help
and i i i do feel a little bit bad about
being sarcastic or doubting that
and some of what they want that fairness
that uh
that equality these are good things and
i'm not against them i just as i say
that always be suspicious when a big
business endorses an idea because
ultimately it's motivated by the bottom
by by how much money it makes um and i i
just i suspect that they're doing this
because it's it's an easy win tim but
come back to uh i just want to finish up
on this idea about uh these values
inclusion diversity surely there's got
to be something there because my
experience when i talk to people in this
country as an outsider someone comes
from russia is people here feel very
guilty about the past
right that is the primary response of
many people about this country's history
of britain being one of the greatest
countries in the history of the world by
the way just to put that out there right
so to me as an outsider that that i
don't get it i don't understand it and i
know it's part of the british tradition
that all well talked about that you know
most intellectuals would rather be seen
stealing from the poor books than
standing for the national anthem but
nonetheless i feel like these movements
for inclusion and diversity in the way
that they are now again i agree with you
equality and all it's very good
they seem to me to be stemming in a very
fundamental
shift in our perception of our past of
our history of our tradition do you do
you feel that's a factor there yeah no
he has to be true that the past can be a
place of learning both for good and bad
and and they very often pick up on the
bad but sometimes you lose a sight of
the the good and we go back to
aspirational ideals uh the good just the
past does throw some up and the problem
is if you just write off the past and
you say basically everyone before this
date was racist and sexist and
uh they were like sort of uh ignorant uh
neanderthals
you lose a lot of good learning as well
i mean i i i think britain is the best
country in the world because it's my
country if i were born if i were born
again i might i may well choose to be
norwegian i get the impression that they
have a much better life than we do but
it's it's instinctive and natural to
people to say this is the best because
it's mine in the same way that you would
say my mum cooks the best flan right she
probably doesn't i'm sure there are some
michelin star chefs much much better but
to you it is the best and that kind of
uh personal attachment to things is
perfectly natural um and i think it's
rather artificial and strange i never
psychologically got it why people don't
feel that it seems it seems normal to me
um and and you're right there there is a
there is a war on the past it is a very
christian idea again i come back to this
is the fascinating complex thing about
tradition is much of what seems to be
kicking against it is actually an
endorsement of it and in a lot of that
language about slavery i hear echoes of
original sin i'm a catholic and this
idea that we did something a long time
ago that was so bad that everything is
stained by it ever since and we've got
to make up for it and the tone for it
well that's a form of original sin
um so
even as people reject british history
they're being incredibly british and
isn't it the ultimately
the most british thing is to be
self-deprecating and say well we're
terrible the only the only problem with
that is you end up an orphan
if you say my family is rotten you
wouldn't believe what my family did
about like 200 years ago nothing to do
with my family well it's all very well
but you wind up an orphan and ultimately
as i've found when you buy a dog you
need someone to walk a dog for you and
if you've written off the rest of the
family uh you've got no one to do it so
no wonder we're feeling so lonely uh
when we've uh when we isolate ourselves
not only from people alive now but
people from the past
it's a great point
one thing i would push back on with the
original sin isn't part of the problem
now with the way we look at things
some people have original sin and some
people don't
right yes yes but that yeah that's true
um i think there's a this can get a bit
weird and niche but i think a lot of
woke is actually calvinist so i said
catholic but that might be the wrong way
to approach it
and in calvinism you have this idea that
some people are going to heaven and only
god knows
and some people are going to hell and
only god knows and it's sort of
it
it's a decision that's taken my twitter
feed
it's something over which it's not that
you have no control but because god
knows everything he already knows
so how are how are we to tell who's
heaven bound and who's hellbound because
we want we want to church we don't want
to let the hell bound people into our
church
so you develop this theory of visible
sainthood
that people have to act like they're
going to heaven they don't know if they
are they're not but they've got to act
like they are and i see some of that in
woke as well
there's this there's this attempt to be
a visible saint by signing up to certain
things using certain language to prove
that you're i'm not going to hell so i
yes you're right some people are
definitely not sinful but it's more than
just even that it's people who might be
sinful are desperately keen to prove
that they're not
and that's what i think we're in right
now is a cult a calvinist cult of
visible sainthood
and
what do you think the future is going to
be do you think that it's because
there's some people who think look this
is here this is here to stay yeah we
have to accept it we have to work within
these remits there's some people who say
no
we need to take it on we need to
challenge it we need to fight it yes
where do we go from here well i could
sell 10 times more books by saying it's
all over and we're doomed
but again my experience of history is
that's not the case because at so many
points in western history we have said
well that's that thing we're finished
and then we've bounced back
everything goes in cycles and everything
moves in fashions um and and in fact
that
come back to poor old madeline must
bring her on the show to to explain
herself we go back we go back to maddie
and young people going to church even
though they don't believe in god that's
very interesting
where is that being transmitted if you
weren't necessarily raised that way if
you don't believe in that why would you
be drawn to this thing i see lots of
young people doing that
the future is yes more tension and chaos
and fuel cues and things like that but
the future is probably also
renaissance restoration because it
always has been
and i i think these
the good things that we've discussed are
so powerful and attractive i do think
they win people back uh it's just up to
a new generation to make the case for
them and that's part of what the point
of the book is i'm making a case for
something that in the past people didn't
feel they had to make a case for to just
take them for granted but no we need to
start all over again and there are lots
of people doing that like jordan
peterson i find peterson's books
fascinating because i read them and i
think this is bloody obvious he's just
saying things that are blindingly
obvious like tied to your room i don't
do it but
he just said he says but there is a
generation of people who don't know
blindingly obvious things and they need
to be reinstructed in them well you were
talking about jordan peterson and that
is such a powerful point because
if you if you were to say if an alien
came down from the skies you asked us
before you came before we started the
show you said who's the biggest person
you've had on have you had jordan
peterson yes
and you go well this canadian professor
who refused to bow down to some
particular law that they introduced in
canada and suddenly he is the biggest
intellectual star in the world or
certainly the western the
english-speaking world
and i think the reason is is the crisis
of meaning that people talk about yes
what
traditionally and historically have
people used human beings used to give
their lives meaning and how does that
differ to us today
um first of all the
peterson literally wrote a book called
maps of meaning of course and and
reading the first time i read him i
thought this is just jung
it's about archetypes uh peterson is
young at heart
and and the point about archetypes is
that you again have these aspirational
ideals that you say to people this is
what a man is like this is what a woman
is like doesn't mean that's what we are
actually like it just means that you
give them templates to people and you
you tell you you explain how to be a
human being through stories uh stories
which you can see you can place yourself
into stories about danger hope uh
charity things like that and that's much
of what religion does it just it gives
us in jesus christ the model of the
perfect person to compare yourself to
as we mentioned earlier freedom um
really all
freedom the individual personality
should be to some extent relational
so that you find meaning in your
relationship uh with other people and
with structures
um
so i i that that's the that i think is
the answer is to find redemption in
other people
how can i help them how can i have a
good relationship with them
how do i fit within a society what is my
role
and how do i serve
rather than beginning from the point of
view of how do i get on
how do i actually flourish as a member
of this community in this society
do you think we're going to see a
resurgence of religion with uh or
christianity with young people
generation z or whatever they're called
going to church on a 11 o'clock on a
sunday morning we're not quite there yet
i mean benedict xvi talked about the
future being a smaller um but more
faithful church that we're moving away
from
the hangover of ethnic religion cultural
religion where you went to church
because it's what your parents did
except well people's parents have
stopped going so certain ideas are not
being transmitted anymore
therefore people will rediscover them in
a whole new way and i think that process
will be very slow and it might be slight
though again i come back to this is
nothing unusual many people were
complaining in the 19th century that
christianity became a very middle class
thing that the working class had drifted
away from the church
so i yes i think the future could be
that but you've got to make it happen
it's certainly that in other societies
um and and we mustn't be too
western-centric uh religion is doing
very well in other countries in latin
america in africa and the middle east
no it's true and and that is a problem
with the west i think is that we have
this naval gazing attitude where we just
look at ourselves and our culture and
our societies without actually looking
outwards yes and we have a habit of
thinking that what how we feel is
universal
uh it's it's very frustrating and again
it's a very christian thing to do this
this idea that uh that it's not just my
god it's the entire world's god
um and what and his laws don't just
apply to me they apply to the entire
world and the west has inherited that
that sense of universalism universality
we very often tell ourselves that our
attitudes towards freedom and our
definitions of what the good life is
everyone either shares them which of
course is nonsense because we know they
don't the taliban don't
or if you took away certain structures
from people's lives they would choose
them
um and they might do it's an experiment
that we keep trying with nation building
but
thus far it hasn't worked
some people do like the way we live
undoubtedly they do
but a lot of people we've discovered
actually don't
you mention the taliban and it's
interesting that you do because some
people have talked about the idea that
you talk about things moving in cycles
in history and of course you're right
um
the idea that what will come
in response to a lack of order
is a craving for order yes that goes too
far in another direction and people
start to seek order from people who
bring it with all sorts of terrible
other things that you know free western
society actually wouldn't and i'm not
talking about islamic fundamentalism
only it could be lots it could take
shape in in other forms are you
concerned about that do you think that's
a possibility i am concerned about that
i mean i'm keen to say in the book that
because people will come back to me and
say look so you want traditional forms
of religion okay well is isis and the
taliban not traditional
well i'm not going to run away from that
to a certain extent they are but i would
argue they are quite untraditional in
their manifestation of religion
for a start they
they don't recognize evolution within
tradition
they want to turn the clock right back
to a fantasy of what things were like in
the 7th century and in some ways things
weren't actually like that i mean a
classic example is isis reintroduced
slavery
for um for yezidis and non-muslims well
there was slavery in the seventh century
but the trend was actually towards
manumission muhammad uh preached
clemency and things like that so so if
anything
islam was moving in a certain direction
they've actually counted that and gone
back they are fanatics and
fundamentalists
they they lack a nuance uh
a nuanced understanding of what religion
is uh and the way that it develops
nevertheless you're right that there
there is a great
worry that if you don't provide answers
if intelligent people rooted in the past
with compassion don't provide answers
and direction then something else will
step in and of course in the 1930s that
was fascism and communism
and that's where it ends um and that
that that is alarming
and people people were having this sort
of conversation in the 1920s and 30s by
the way right so you you can't rule out
fascism and europe has a history of
doing it
um
we we are just as capable of being
brutal and nasty as any other part of
the world
and that's reassuring that is very
reassuring
one thing i've really enjoyed about this
interview is
i i assume you're a conservative
uh in in your politics would you would
you not not with a capital c
but
okay but i would say that unlike small c
conservatives there's you're quite
optimistic oh i'm very optimistic yes
and i find that quite
incongruous i would say as a world
because a lot of the time when i talk to
conservatives and i have conservative
leanings as well particularly small c
conservative leanings i think they're
rooted in pessimism a lot of the time
yes they seem to be well you know if
only we could go back to you know when
when we respected marriage or when we
respected tradition you wouldn't have
all this [ __ ]
right bring back hang on right but you
speak you see what i mean
there's there's an optimism which i
don't often see in a lot of people
what i would say to them is two things
one if you want
life to be a certain way live it
and many of them do
but i just think it's incumbent upon the
individual if you think marriage is
important right okay go and find
yourself a wife and have lots and lots
of kids it begins with you don't just
berate society it begins with you the
second thing i would say is that i think
it's it's almost unchristian to be to
despair indeed it is it is unchristian
to despair because christians at heart
believe that jesus christ is coming back
things are going to be okay
so if you go around zero it's all over
and it's done but that's a very young
christian attitude it's also quite an
unbritish attitude again one of those uh
things i was raised to think british's
britishness was
was a stiff upper lip um
and there's a wonderful scene uh in
which i always like to quote in carrying
up the kaiba uh when the palace is being
stormed and someone says to sir sydney
rough diamond what shall we do
and so sydney says do we're british
we'll do nothing
and finally and particularly americans
who are apocalyptic that's the most
un-american
attitude america is all about positivity
and being upbeat so if you want to
revive these traditions live them but
also these traditions
one of the reasons why they keep going
is because they have faith in the future
and their ability and their and
self-confidence in their ability to
persevere and to flourish and to flower
and to change and to grow
so i think it's very
i i i to me it is actually going against
the spirit of tradition to say it's all
over and we're doomed all right i'm
we're not going to ask you any more
questions because it's nice to end on a
positive note after the conversation
we've just had
so we'll wrap it up there other than to
say tim uh brilliant book thanks so much
for coming on whatever happened to
tradition and uh we have one final
question for you as always which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be
anything other than politics
that is my one big complaint about the
modern world is his obsession with
politics and it isn't it isn't
the terminus of everything we've
discussed which is the rise of
liberalism and the idea that everything
in life can be debated and sorted out
and therefore if you believe that
literally every single element of your
life not just from economics but to who
should be the next james bond is
discussed in political terms and i would
just like to go for a week in this
country in which we don't talk about
politics that would be the most radical
radical proposition i can imagine amen
my friend amen uh tim stanley thank you
so much we're going to ask you a couple
of quick questions for locals but in the
meantime thanks for so much for coming
on and thank you for watching and
listening at home we'll see you with
another brilliant interview like this
one very very soon or you can catch a
raw show at exactly the same time 7 p.m
british standard time 2 p.m eastern
standard or if you like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below